foreign
I screwed up I hit the wrong button okay
what's up
I'm doing good how about yourself better
now how can I help
uh yes so I have a quick question
um I currently have about 60 000 in my
savings account and I'm not too sure
what to do next I definitely want to
make my money grow so I no there's like
a slow process where you could do like a
saving certificate but I want to see if
there's any other options that will
definitely help me get
um you know um I guess more money built
up uh or such
well done where'd you get the sixty
thousand
I've been saving since before College
job that I recently got
um and other side hustles that I've been
doing that just has helped me uh
accumulate the amount
Elena that's amazing way to go do you
have any debt
no not at the moment I'm curious how did
you pay for college
uh with college I had um a ton of
scholarly scholarships I also had
private scholarships
um and then I would pay school if I had
any money that I had to owe from the
school I did have a part-time job at the
time where I would just use the money to
pay it off while also saving
you're amazing way to go that's just
incredible I love that just out of
curiosity for myself where did you get
that mindset how did you learn so early
on that you wanted to save aggressively
that you wanted your savings account to
look like that
well it all started when I first got my
job
um having I was paid cash so having that
money in my hands
um and being able to like see how much
it goes down with buying something from
the store just taught me that I I wanted
to have my hands full with money not
empty by just purchasing random stuff
and so the first thing that I saved up
for that was pretty big was a car
and I I was able to learn that you can
get most of what whatever you want you
just have to look hard enough that's how
I was able to find my first car for
three thousand dollars and from there
that helped a ton since I didn't have to
do monthly payments or anything
so what do you do for a living
so right now I'm a data scientist I had
a uh or a car dealership yeah what do
you make
about 84 000. good for you okay so
here's the thing that we teach the
shortest distance between where you are
and being wealthy is a series of steps
maybe step one and save a thousand
dollars you've done that two is to be
debt free other than your home you've
done that three is to have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
so we would earmark some of your sixty
thousand for your emergency fund uh we
could call that fifteen thousand pretty
comfortably as an example okay which
would still leave you sixty five
thousand dollars what are we gonna do
with that we're gonna move on to baby
step four and or start you earmark this
for saving towards a home either one
you're thinking about buying a home
anytime soon
uh I wouldn't see a home just yet
um I do have a partner and we're
thinking of buying a property so that we
can
um
make uh I guess rent it out with other
homes like uh mobile homes and such yeah
I would not do that
I would not do that don't buy real
estate with Partners if you want to buy
some real estate you buy the real estate
but you don't need a partner to do that
um okay
you're going to involve yourself in a
mess that you're going to end up
untangling later the only ship that
won't sales a partnership
so I assume that you mean that kind of
business partner is that what you meant
no uh an actual relationship partner
okay well if you're not married to
someone don't buy a house with them
okay that's what I'm saying because
you're setting yourself up again for all
kinds of problems uh if this doesn't go
if this relationship doesn't go forward
so if you're married there's a
methodology called divorce that takes
the property and splits it up there's
not when you're not and so don't do that
now as far as then then what we would
just move on to is you're just an
investor okay you're either going to buy
real estate with this other 65 000 and
or you're going to start putting money
into your
uh into your retirement plan into good
growth stock mutual funds we recommend
that you put 15 of your income every
year at baby step four into a good
growth stock mutual funds into a
retirement plan and that's uh if you've
got a 401k at work you get the match
first if it's a Roth 401k you can stay
there otherwise after the match you
would need to move on and do Roth IRAs
uh and the mutual funds are growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international you're looking for mutual
funds with long track records 10 20
30-year track records and you need to
learn about those as you're putting
money into that sit down with one of our
smartvester Pros they'll help you do
that the smartvestor pros don't work for
us but they're people that teach the
same stuff that we teach and they'll
help you with uh picking out the mutual
funds teach you that they're investment
Brokers you can find them at
ramsesolutions.com and click on Smart
investor Pro so
yeah that's a a
you know the process we would use to to
lead you there Hang on we're going to
send you a copy of The Total Money
Makeover book which outlines that for
you in great detail So Christine the big
the only the only she had done so many
things right but she could undo every
bit of it with one wrong move and that's
buying a house with someone you're not
married to or buying a investment
property with someone you're not married
to uh and
that will get you into a mess yeah we've
seen that several times and and I think
that's kind of a dangerous spot whenever
you don't have a proven plan it's easy
to start to get to that wealth building
spot and see all the tick tock phrases
and see all the different you know quick
ways to make money and it's like you can
get really lost in that but Elena you
have done such an amazing job thus far I
love that you've been so aggressive with
your savings follow the plan it's not
the most flashy you know you know Tick
Tock crazy plan but it's proven it has
worked everything as if we ought to put
the plan on Tic Tac that could be good
let's do it yeah I told the guys to get
get it get us a Tic Tac account and
let's get it on there I'm ready for it
so